ex james bond girl voici la solitaire de
lives and let die jane seymour marie
antoinette et dont l'une est alors joyce
pénélope wilhelmine à franck halberg tu
as changé ton nom pour jane seymour qui
est la femme que l'on réduise
barbe-bleue a épousé le lendemain de la
mort d'anne boleyn et donc c'est tout
est normal que tu joues marie-antoinette
finalement donné que j'avais choisi un
nom brême non
10 g/j d'une changer le nom parce que de
nom d'origine allemand c'est trop long
trop étrange est impossible et tout le
monde peut dire prendre fin
c'est pas ça marche pas mais j'ai
toujours mis dans tous les journaleux
m'ont pas énorme entre ce qui est de sa
wii ça s'est passé comment ce rôle de
marie antoinette à la very good to be
the queen ne s'accordent pas mal oui à
paris ça et tout ça mais c'était écrit
par un écrivain anglais
je pense qu'il a pu regarder l'histoire
de la durance objets et aussi pas venir
à moi nous avons choisi de faire
beaucoup de recherches de le roi la
reine et nous avons trouvé les choses
nous avons essayé de montrer la femme
derrière la reine
muriel roi qui sont les vrais et c'est
pas le contraire les juges en effet être
carrie culture est comme ça c'est
célébrer les une famille quand même dans
le temps présent les enfants là bas ils
ont soudé les problèmes pour continuer
dans notre petit chambre on peut voir
c'est une vraie famille tu pensé quoi la
révolution française avant de faire le
film toi c'était quoi ton opinion sur la
révolution en angleterre en fait rien de
dans l'histoire de prendre les français
sauf qu'on est en guerre et les enduits
peut gagner dans le temps de dix hommes
antoine on en entend de large et
français s'est marié en est qui a dit il
essaie tous les autres manger du gâteau
avec la terre c'est juste que ça c'est
juste ça mais maintenant tu penses quoi
non je pense que les carottes c'était
quelque chose d'affreux moi j'ai pensé
après après le tournage que si le roi et
la reine ont eu la chance
un choix ils ont ils ont pu faire une
sans paniquer comme en angleterre
constitution on peut la voir une reine
oui bien sûr ce chiffre attendu peur
avec les pneus est ce que tu penses
comme margaret thatcher que les droits
de l'homme ont été inventés en
angleterre 200 ans avant la france parce
que tu sais qu'elle a dit ça pour le
bicentenaire de la révolution française
ça fait un scandale ont ranimé je pense
que c'est pas très gentil de dire ça
pendant le
sans terre mais ils ont les gens ont des
projets qui font ce pourquoi les
français veut montrer au monde un
désastre parce que par toute la
révolution est bien c'est beaucoup des
problèmes c'est ce qu'on voit en voyant
ses malheurs ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que non seulement tu t'appelles
jane seymour mais qu'en plus tu vis dans
un château fort que tu as acheté un
château un manoir près de près de
bristol un manoir o'grady xvème siècle
pas vraiment une ligne pure merveille
que leur suivi comme ça où il y avait
les antiquités des bijoux anciens ne
sont pas été une vie de château de vie
en ordre mais je gémis aussi en fait 2
kgs anglais général gilles enfants qui
vont à l'école c'est très flatteur parce
que ton en jambes très content parce que
temps larry david lean jouer au polo
avec le prince charles
je veux dire c'est très bien oui
peut-être c'est chic c'est aussi cher
les obligent les pour le phoning oui toi
tu as deux enfants kate hudson disque
est très intéressant c'est que honda 10
pour le film bon si dame en mariant
colette elle avait deux enfants et on a
cherché des enfants qui te ressembler
mais à un moment tu as dis mais pourquoi
on prend pas les miens c'est finalement
c'est vrai pour trouver des fonds parce
que pour trouver des enfants des
poissons c'est sûr que les tiens donc y
joue dans le film y en a qui fait le
petit dauphin et électricité tels que
madame royal il en manquerait
photographe s'est marié avec les 13
enfants
on y suivait très longue et douce le
petit dauphin
c'est exactement le même que mon fils et
torons il était enfin de ce bien sans
bien ils sont passés en janvier
mais là ils sont reconduits à poney et
des enfants en découvrant la façon dont
on a traité cette famille la réalité un
la famille les les émotions du fan 2009
en a qui perdent tout et enfin ils
sortent les enfants sont petits d'opa tu
parle très bien le français
ah merci maintenant très très bien par
contre je vais faire une interview une
forme d'interview tu dois répondre
seulement par oui ou par non
même si tu répondais en anglais ou
américains ça serait aussi simple
au fait
ce qu'ils font
qu'est ce que tu penses que ça va durer
comme ça que tu vas continuer à faire
des grands pu être une star
étudier en angleterre mais qui passent
beaucoup de temps les oules enfin bon
est ce que tu penses que ça va continuer
oui est ce que tu penses qu'il faut
coucher pour réussir un bon coup chez
couché avec non chez vous non vraiment
pas ah bon non est-ce que tu qui traite
ou pour un grand amour sur demain matin
tu joues dans un film et bien l'acteur
qui est en face de toi c'est vraiment tu
te dis c'est le quatrième homme de ma
vie parce que tu qui traite non je
quitterai pas d'avis les ans tu es qui
traitent pas non je peux pas j'ai les
enfants que j'adore passer les enfants
oui mais c'est aussi mon mari mes jeux g
on peut tomber en amour mais c'est pas
nécessaire d
et
les petites aventures mais cela s'est
passé mais je suis par contre très
nombreux cas avant non depuis sept ans
que avec oman
oui j'ai jamais rencontré un fou
empêcher doit être bien seul il est bien
et il a bien il aimait tient toujours
supprimés
est ce que tu dis des expériences de
insect tu vois un type comme ça qu'ils
ont envie de faire l'amour avec lui dans
les 30 secondes
ah oui passé ah oui ça m'est arrivé oui
bon avoir pas pensé avant
bien sûr c'est un jeu est-ce que ça mais
c'était pas de penser qu'amd oui ça
c'est dit
30 minutes trois minutes lors des trois
minutes trente minutes est-ce que c'est
très personnel
est-ce que nice est très personnel c'est
comment tu as et milan s'est passé parce
que quand ça s'est passé c'est la langue
j'étais super c'est une chanson qui
passe très très peur j'espère est ce que
pour faire l'amour est ce que tu
t'arrive de laisser la lumière a lui
même tué train systématiquement la
lumière donc j'insiste je mets un jeu
super skis
si cet allumé toute sa vie mais c'est un
mec il change pas le nom je suis prêt si
ça fait très très pas seulement ça et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux